[Music]
on this episode of travel dares I'm
taking Caroline to zip world to try the
world's fastest zipline and I'm here at
the Ponca salsa aqueducts where we're
gonna canoe a hundred and 26 feet in the
air come join us on our adventures on
this episode of travel dares
welcome to travel dears I'm Caroline and
in this episode we're in Wales with my
friend agent Wells is known for its
rolling countryside and rich history
with some of the most picturesque
landscapes you'll ever see
I use my merry a bon vivant list card on
all of my trips so that I can earn two
times the points on my everyday
practices agent how excited are you I am
so excited are you ready for your first
clue so ready
head first okay very clever oh I hope I
don't have a helmet for this AJ if its
head first you'll be okay
I don't know I don't know I feel like
you are very adventurous so I Caroline's
never done anything like this before and
even though it'll be a little
intimidating it's the perfect way to
push her out of her comfort zone I'm
gonna set you right there baby bear I
feel like we're really high up there's a
railing oh you know you're wearing
something you're definitely wearing okay
this is it for oh my God thank you bye
football okay because we're going down
the world's fastest zipline oh my gosh
this is so high up
[Music]
zip 12 aussicht who is the most unique
ride it's the longest ride in the
northern hemisphere we've got the world
record for the fastest zipline in the
world we have broken that record twice
now the zipline takes approximately 56
seconds to do one mile and drop over
1,200 feet all right how do I look great
you look good too we are on our way to
the big boy big one it is but you know
what no turning back now we have to do
it you know I just can't think about it
I just have to go let's just go let's do
it do it okay
oh my gosh okay I think I'm just just
getting strapped in now AJ where are you
get him strapped in
uh-uh it's a lot higher from this angle
here we go here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you first like step up the platform
it feels like this is the end this is
the last thing you're gonna see and you
start picking up speed and it just gets
so much better it just gets like so
relaxing and you just get to sit and
just stare at the view around you AJ
that was so much fun thank you so much
for bringing me here Carolina you were
so brave today I'm so impressed everyone
talks about how Wales is so beautiful
and honestly I think this is the best
way to see it AJ you're clear all right
here we go
don't look down so we're going up high
tight wait and see I'm gonna be like
skydiving pull it down I think I'm gonna
like dangle off something or pushed off
something or jump off something really
high AJ loves thrill rides and the
combination of the intense height with
the Zen activity is something he's never
done before this adventure is gonna be
the perfect way for AJ to see the Welsh
countryside
all right okay you stand here take off
your blindfold because we are going
canoeing over a hundred twenty feet in
the air are you kidding
this is so cool we're headed in that
direction
[Music]
well I'm then welcome to the club step
it up so are you guys ready to go yeah
I'm totally ready let's do it
brilliant this is an amazing way to get
quite a thrill seek from going canoeing
on a canal that then paddle 126 foot
above the river with the sheer side edge
to look over it is quite quite
impressive to people be able to do it's
great that we've got it to be able to do
it here protip don't fall yeah alright
okay we just can't shake the boat yeah
we can't lock the boat weird huh
I'm very excited I'm a little nervous
but I'm really excited to see this view
alright I think I hear like a stream
yeah we're on the big boy bridge yeah
over here we're getting risky we're
getting oh my gosh look at this Wow
we are higher than the birds right now
we are we're literally higher than the
birds the birds flying below beautiful
it's the highest and the longest in
Great Britain of aqueducts it's
obviously been standing for over 200
years it's a significant feat of
Engineering is why is it being dominated
of the World Heritage Sites if I was
celebrating ten years of having World
Heritage Site inscription this year you
know I think the views here and it's nip
world are two of the most beautiful
games you can see in a way honestly I
think this is one of the most serene
views I've ever seen AJ did you have a
good time oh it was dope I loved it so
much I'm so glad
I had such an amazing time in Wales it
was both of our first time here and it
was way more beautiful than I thought it
would be there's no better way to end
our UK experience and with a nice cup of
tea back at the hotel this is actually
the oldest hotel in Bristol it's like a
hundred and fifty years old really
that's a very classic AJ how do you
think I did on my fear well when I
revealed that we were going down the
world's fast as if life I really thought
you're gonna be scared but you're
actually really excited even when we got
to the top of the mountains staring down
1,500 meters of zipline cable you were
excited and ready to go so for that I'm
giving you 5 out of 5 stars
yeah I love a good 5 out of 5 thank you
no it was really fun it was such an
exhilarating feeling and the views were
beautiful so I really really did enjoy
it Caroline I had a great time but I
have to know what is my rating okay so
honestly AJ I was really impressed of
how well you handled this dare you went
straight to the front of the boat and
you commute really well and you even
looked over the bridge and you weren't
even scared so for those reasons ageing
you're getting a 5 out of 5 stars that's
what I wanted
AJ finish your tea because we have a
flight to catch
I am so ready for this next year pinkies
up
[Music]